Hello Freak bitches.
It just doesn't seem like a huge product gets everybody gets their phone ruined
by pouring a drink on it.
Like that's the number one reason phones get ruined.
I would say cracked screens.
Toilet.
I will take cracked.
Screens are probably higher than water,
but they're both high.
Speaking of cracked screens,
cracked screens.
Almost universal.
Right.
Does everybody get a cracked screen?
I've never had one,
but I've had to move a Turd to get my phone out of.
Out of the toilet.
Did you kill the phone or the phone?
Survive.
How long was it in English?
It literally like I got up and then it fell in the toilet and I was like God put
my hand through her and grabbed it,
pulled it out and then.
And then just write it off.
Put it in a bag of right now.
It didn't even wash his hands as far.
Now I did the shaky thing and the good enough hairdryer.
Oh really?
What you should do if that happens is 24 hours in a bag of rice.
Yeah,
it'll.
It'll pull away moisture.
What I usually end up just doing,
then having something stopped working and then take it to the APP or call the
apple store and they will send you one with that.
Apple's great with that.
Here's the weird thing though.
They put,
or at least they used to.
I don't know anymore.
I used to do some repairs on these things,
crack them open and get crazy like that,
but they used to put little litmus paper in there that would show.
Got Wet.
It would turn red.
He used to be in the headphone Jack.
I don't know.
They probably still do it.
Still do it,
but that.
But if you call they don't.
There's no way from their check when I say,
here's a question,
when you say if you drop something in the toilet,
drop upon the children,
should you shut it off and throw it in the bag of rice?
Oh,
should you leave time to turns itself off,
but it.
Yeah.
If you.
If it's still on,
turn it,
turn it off.
Shut it off.
So shut it off.
Throw it in the bag of rice.
Yeah.
What I usually do is just suck the water out of it,
but,
but I wasn't going to do it with the poop ones.
Why not?
Because when you suck it off,
if you look at your iphone,
like there's the top part where the.
That's where your ear usually goes,
but there's water that's in there.
So you stuck that and you're like pretty much sucking earwax.
It's gross.
I never,
I never thought of talking on my phone.
Ever been to that.
You mean like I go really hard many times.
Have you done this?
Probably like five times.
So where's your fault when
you're going that you're getting earwax.
If you look,
if you look,
there's like a little grill that's right there and if you look really close you
could actually see their shit in there.
I was thinking about the Jack itself,
but you have to suck all of them.
There's the bottom one that you suck.
You suck like power.
Does that work?
Can you really suck the water out?
Will really help.
That's what I'll always do.
You mean getting,
getting water away from it is going to be a positive thing,
but
the guy on the phone,
customer service here,
listen,
I've been sucking on my phones that cool.
I'm just saying in the most polite way possible.
I wouldn't recommend it.
No.
Well,
and that's a problem because we have capitalized and privatized the
education system to hear such a degree.
I mean if you.
If you got a degree in Australia where rights,
Macquarie University or Sydney University or University of New South Wales,
it's an Mba.
One of us.
Google's is exactly same as an mba at any one of our schools here.
You know you had not only does an MBA matter that all of a sudden and it has to
be from the right school,
so an Mba from Harvard or an Ivy League school is trump's and mba from
university of San Diego or something like that and that shouldn't be the way and
affect what that does.
It still keeps propelling that plutocracy because there was a study done that at
least for every student at Harvard,
a student and have.
It has at least one parent earning at least for $100,000 per year.
So we're still,
you know,
with the capitalization of everything.
We're,
we're forming a system where we have,
you know,
the very wealthy at the top and we have everybody's struggling in the bottom
that the elite ism involved in education is really fascinating to me today.
Especially because there's so much access to information,
so many books,
so much online,
so much to read and just you can get so much access to information that would,
you know,
a long time ago.
The difference between going to Harvard and go into San Diego state was pretty
gigantic.
But what with what you have access to today,
the average person has access to the exact same information that they're
teaching at any school anywhere.
But I had a conversation with a friend of mine and he was wrong about something
and I brought up this woman who had.
She had went to the University of Mississippi,
but she went there and this was her major.
Like this thing that we were talking about.
And he goes,
well,
this guy went to Yale.
But he didn't even go to jail for that.
He went to jail for something else and he's 80.
Okay.
So he went to Yale and like the 19 sixties,
who knows what the fuck they were teaching back then.
Like what are you talking about man,
you know,
like,
but the eye,
his first initial reaction was,
look,
she went to the University of Mississippi,
he went to Yale.
I'm like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
But that is the way we think in this country
it is.
And also not only is it the way we think,
but you know,
these kids that are going to mit or harvard or Yale,
well it's the networks I take with them.
So when the jobs are about,
you know,
the only growth area that we have in this country as a technology jokes.
But that's such an inshallah job market where only the networks,
the alumni from these prestigious schools get to really apply from all the kids
working at Google.
They all went to these fancy schools that could be afforded by the wealthy
parents.
Collin quit a long time ago reminded me many,
many years.
My first,
like on an opiod,
anthony,
I was dating a British girl and she was a real pervert,
like I drove a Saturn back then I still lived in Jersey and I used to fucking
park outside of Dangerfield and she would blow me.
I would trap.
She liked,
been to trap her head under my steering wheel and she would go like,
I want you to bite me,
I want you to bite me.
Like she would repeat this mantra of me biting her on her back.
She liked to be bitten and brutalized by her back and she was like,
I want you to make me suck it,
and then I would hold her head under the wheel and she'll be trapped under my
Saturday steering wheel
and fucking she would suck my dick and lick my balls and whatever.
Good kid.
He was a good girl.
Yeah.
Her name is ruth.
She was a really cool girl.
Ruth.
Yeah.
Good five and talked to her in 15 years,
but she was a great guy.
Mr. Terribly.
I think you went back across the pond.
Hello?
As they say.
And what was the point of the story of the Colon?
She was really loud when I ate her pussy.
Really super loud.
And it was,
she say,
I don't remember.
Just moaning and groaning.
One of those things.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever it was.
I
beat my pussy like it's Manchester United,
but I can't.
It was a really low and puts you a sloppy fucking wet.
Like it was legit.
Like I knew she wasn't putting on a show because her pussy was sloppy,
but I was going to eat her pussy on the air be a year.
This is before I was I get everyday and be a good quality and your pussy on the
air and I was going to do that.
And Collin Quinn stopped me and he goes,
you know,
and he goes,
you can do that.
You could put them in.
You're a comic.
You got to say funny shit.
You don't want to be that guy that does wacky things.
And I'm like,
I never forgot that.
He was almost telling me,
don't be a stunt boy.
You gotta say it funny.
You got to sit there and be funny verbally and I maybe in that case he was right
because I wasn't the gun,
the Wacko who call up at eight pussy on the air.
It's like I have to be able to be funny in my delivery and say,
and I was like,
eh.
That was kind of a good point.
Looking back in hindsight,
I probably should have eaten or pussy on the going to be a very funny clip.